now come back to a Hillary angle again
right the way that we got insight into
these objects is we took this right hand
side and we said don't write it like
that in a small form even though it's
nice and simple write it in a expanded
form because then you can work with it
you can compare things so can you expand
this for me let's just treat it as a
normal distance what are you gonna do so
you're pairing up terms just like you
normally do when you're multiplying out
anything minus beta X what else you're
onto the second pair now right minus
alpha X I heard it okay so all we've
done is expand all we've done is expand
but I wonder if the gears are turning
for you when you have a look at the left
and you have a look at the right and you
realize these must be the same object
they must be the same for starters have
a look unsurprisingly you have an x
squared on both sides that's not
surprising because they are the same
object right so being that I don't gain
any understanding about all of the A's
and B's and C's and alphas and betas
because of these guys these guys are
independent I'm just going to get rid of
them okay so I get this okay now over
here I could rewrite this just as it is
right but remember what I was trying to
do with auxilary angle I want to clarify
that there are coefficients here I can
compare right so see over here there's a
coefficient of x this takes a bit of
twisting first to work out what the
coefficient of x is I'm going to factor
eyes out right so if I take a factor of
x out of these two terms here what do I
get
what am I left with after I take out the
X negative beta minus alpha right
because I usually write X's laughs I'm
going to write the fact you just told me
I'm going to write it first okay so
negative beta minus alpha that's how
many X's there are are you with me like
the reason I'm factorizing is because I
want to see these X's and this X and
look at them together side by side and
then lastly you have this guy hanging
out
alpha yeah okay now I'm going to do one
more step and this time I'm going to do
it in some colors to highlight what's
going on because it'll be my last light
okay over here on the left hand side how
many X's do I have this is how many
that's how many X's I've got I'll come
to the rest of the left hand side in a
second how many X's do I have on the
right hand side well I'm going to take
out a minus sign as well because that
just looks awkward having so many minus
signs in there I would write it like
this
I'm also going to put it alphabetically
is that okay do you see that's the
coefficient of x like so now in addition
to my X terms on both sides they also
have a constant term do you see that
this is just the constant know X is
attached right so how much of a constant
term do I have on each side what on the
Left I've got this maybe or this much of
a concert what do I have in the record
zone this sides this okay now the colors
spell it out right I can now do just
like I did with auxilary angle a proper
comparison of these coefficients because
I have the left on the right hand side
looking very different but supposedly
being the same object okay so therefore
all right here I'm going to use exactly
the same line I use back in order the
angle which is by a comparison of
coefficients the X terms have a look I
can say be on a equals this yeah that's
just the orange bit and likewise
or conversely see on a equals this okay
now
if you have a look at these and remember
what alpha and beta are actually you
know meaning because that's what I
introduced back at the beginning alpha
and beta are the roots alpha beta are
the roots so therefore you can sort of
tie this up indeed Bo by saying what if
that minus sign was on the other side
right I can say look there's green if
you take the roots alpha beta and you
add them up alpha plus beta alpha plus
beta I can say the sum of the roots
because that's what alpha plus beta is
is that negative sign should be on the
other side right - be on a yeah whereas
down here you're not adding up roots are
you are multiplying them which is why we
call it the product of the roots which
this is nice it doesn't require any
judgment at all this is just C on a so
when you hear a phrase some product of
roots this is what's being referred to
okay what's interesting about this is I
know nothing about a or B or C or alpha
and beta but I can go straight to the
relationship between them without
actually finding out no quadratic
formula no actual factorizing involved I
just kind of pretend the builds a
factorization and worked out what
happens okay question so we're focusing
on quadratics at the moment as it turns
out these two results over here which
are called via test results after the
French mathematician V okay um he
generalized these so that you could get
the sum and product of roots for a
quadratic or cubic or aquatic or aquatic
or anything you like and we'll come to
that a bit later on under the topic of
polynomials when we break out of just
degree two and have a look at three and
four and so on okay art note correct
right
okay so let's just have a look at what
this means he okay
now we're gonna look at two quadratic
this is a quick example right whatever
summon products of roots in this case
well I could launch into the quadratic
formula
why would I launch it a quadratic
formula by the way because it doesn't
look like it's going to be very fun to
factorize right I don't know pairs of
numbers that multiply to negative one
practice just negative one and one we
know that's I can do the job however if
all I want to do is work out the
relationship between the roots I don't
need to work out what the roots are I
can simply work out the sum of roots and
the product of roots directly from just
reading off the coefficients so have a
look if after the speeder is minus B or
a what's minus B on a in this case my is
3 over 1 which is of course very
strictly the product of roots is just C
on a so have a look - sorry positive C
on a so it's just that that's it I don't
have to work out what they are I can go
straight to this relationship because of
this pattern here ok now when it gets
really interesting I'm just going to
show you these results and then let them
sit for a little while ok if you have a
look at something like say this x
squared plus bless you let's do this guy
okay hmm
perfect when you have a look at
something like this I can do exactly the
same exercise it's just as easy a plus
beta is going to be minus B on a minus B
on a which is negative 2 the product of
roots is going to be C on a which is now
when it gets really interesting and why
this is so perplexing is that you
actually know something about this
quadratic without having worked out this
something specific about it right the
discriminant in this case is going to be
b squared minus 4ac which in this case
will be what's 4ac xx now you don't even
need to evaluate that to tell me the
discriminate in this case is going to be
negative which means you can classify
this quadratic right you can classify it
this quadratic here has a positive value
for a negative value for the
discriminant so what kind of a quadratic
is it it's facing art so it's positive
and it never has any roots so it's
positive definite does that make sense
wait hold on a second no roots no roots
no roots but apparently excuse me
there's non-existent roots can be both
added and multiply it and they give you
some very reasonable happy looking
numbers unlike say the quadratic formula
which promptly explodes on okay so this
is really interesting then I can work
out the sum product of roots number one
without having to appear to the
quadratic formula but number two I can
work out the some products of roots even
when the quadratic formula fails
hmm